on va faire le point sur tout ça avec
notre invité clément gignac et le vice
président principal économiste en chef
chez industrielle alliance on le rejoint
dans nos studios de toronto bonjour
monsieur gignac
bonsoir alors explique moi ce qui se
passe grosse journée pour la politique
monétaire on va se concentrer sur le
canada d'abord on wii se tourner vers le
statu quo encore une fois mais on a
senti beaucoup de prudence aujourd'hui
l'inquiétude peut-être avec des
prévisions abaissées pour les deux
prochaines années
quelle est votre lecture de cette
décision de clermain monsieur paul howes
le démonte une inquiétude un peu plus
grande que ce qu'on a vu par le passé au
niveau des risques on a au niveau des
tensions géopolitiques et finalement les
impacts que ce après avoir sur
l'économie canadienne
on a même fait une étude spéciale à la
fin pour mentionner que si le conflit
commercial avec la chine et les tensions
géopolitiques s'aggravait bien ce
moment-là l'économie canadienne sera une
économique serait pas mal frappé au
niveau des pays choisis en raison de
notre statut d'exportateur de ressources
naturelles donc les prix des matières
premières pourrait baisser et ont même
évoqué que dark indien pourrait 15% plus
benoît ne restait un peu surpris au
niveau du ton qui était utilisé par le
band quindio même s'il y avait pas
vraiment de surprise ou fait qu'il y
avait cette fois clairement et signale
que c'est les choses se détériore de
nouveau ils seront prêts à bouger aux
hôtes aussi avec des baisses de taux ça
parce que la clé le mot qui est revenu
souvent aujourd'hui c'est là que les
alliances pour l'instant de l'économie
canadienne combien de temps à votre avis
avant qu'on se fasse rattraper par ce
mouvement mondial mais faut voir parce
que l'économie canadienne va quand même
très bien le consommateur résume bien
comme c'est mentionné le secteur
immobilier en fait même repartis à la
hausse
faut comprendre c'est économique
indienne et doper du fait parce qu'on a
quand même nous faire croissance
démographique avec une forte poussée du
côté de l'immigration tout cela
contribue à créer de la richesse une
forte demande aussi du côté de
l'immobilier
mais pour que l'économie puisse
connaître une croissance une expansion
soutenable
il faut également que d'autres sling
sont à l'oeuvre au niveau du moteur
économique indien c'est à dire des
dépenses d'investissement et au niveau
des exportations
et c'est là qu'on une inquiétude la
banque du canada qu'on peut pas se fier
uniquement l'immobilier au consommateur
il faut vraiment être les dépenses
investissements et les exportations soit
au rendez vous faut avoir une croissance
équilibrée
ses seules inquiétudes d'ailleurs et on
a un peu l'impression que bon si on
mettait encore le statu quo c'est
peut-être seulement une question de
temps avant qu'ils aient des baisses
parce que pour l'instant la banque du
canada fait un peu cavalier seul les
banques centrales un peu partout dans le
monde a baissé leurs taux directeur en
même temps d'économie quinzaine de voix
bien comme savez la création d'emplois
au cours des neuf premiers mois a été la
plus forte en 17 ans et contrairement
aux autres banques centrales la banque
center prend un problème pour atteindre
sa cible d'inflation de 2 % donc alors
que l'opinion de la misère et que la
cible d'inflation le canada on est à la
cible d'inflation de 2 %
qui plus est les sexes les salaires
s'accélère au niveau du canada donc dans
ce sens là c'est une source de réconfort
par contre faut comprendre que si des
choses s'est détériorée au niveau de
géopolitique au niveau international le
que les tensions commerciales c'est
grèverait le canada qui est un pays de
ressources naturelles pourraient être
affectés donc clairement on lance kipawa
une police d'assurance de ne pas trop
s'inquiéter en même temps on signale
qu'on va suivre de près la politique
fiscale avec un gouvernement minoritaire
on pourrait avoir des baisses d'impôts
une simulation au prochain budget qui
pourrait venir compenser les
ralentissements ou les vents contraires
qu'on a du côté commercial donc du côté
de la banque du canada monsieur gignac
on a gardé le cap aujourd'hui et aux
états unis on a choisi d'y aller avec
une troisième baisse de taux directeurs
alors que l'économie américaine on l'a
vu encore aujourd'hui 1,9 pour cent de
croissance on veut la stimuler au canada
on maintient le cap alors que la
croissance est inférieure et indiens et
car claire entre les deux oui puis quand
on écoute des conférences de presse cet
accord accueillant pas été moins buffet
l'autre les remises mais au niveau de
niveau de l'économie américaine garder à
l'esprit que contrairement au canada ils
y ont de la misère à atteindre leur
cible d'inflation qui plusieurs études
le taux directeur de la réserve fédérale
était déjà beaucoup plus haut que celui
de la banque du canada
donc aujourd'hui on le ramène au même
niveau qu'avant puisqu'il doit on est
passé de 2 et demi à 1,75 toi baisses de
taux consécutives la part de la réserve
fédérale dans un contexte où le chômage
est à son plein emploi le plus fervent
saint quentin c'est déjà beaucoup
d'un point de vue des autorités
monétaires que comme
action de belles autos par contre quand
on regarde on écoute et les conférences
de presse aujourd'hui
andréanne c'est que c'est clair qu'il y
avait une différence
il semble y avoir un plus grand
optimisme quant à la suite des choses du
côté de monsieur pawar et voit un
soulagement
ou du moins des signes positifs du côté
des négociations commerciales chine
etats unis
même du côté du gros exit alors que du
côté la banque du canada on exprimait
plutôt des inquiétudes pour la suite des
choses dont ça c'était vraiment
intéressant
la divergence de vue sur la suite des
choses
la suite des choses justement monsieur
gignac bon la fed laissé entendre qu'on
pourrait peut-être marque une pause du
côté de la banque du canada a qu'un une
baisse du taux directeur mais il faut
voir
moi personnellement je n'y crois pas
parce que je pense que monsieur bah
voilà raison que d'une amélioration au
niveau de géopolitique et finalement au
niveau de la banque du canada avec
l'icône immobilier qui reprend avec eux
le fait que pendant qu'on assistera un
budget un peu plus actif avec des
baisses d'impôts je pense que ce sera
promène pas nécessaire d'abaisser
d'études
on va se le dire le petit meneur
canadien est quand même pas été beaucoup
moins restrictive que la politique
monétaire américaine avec un taux
directeurs à bas du taux d'inflation au
canada alors ce qui est elle opposée aux
états unis dont jacob pas une très
grande probabilité qu'on a une baisse de
taux de la banque du canada
mais disons que c'était une police
d'assurance il voulait rassurer les gens
peau dit qu'il n'était pas dogmatique
mais lui aussi pour abaisser les taux si
jamais la situation se détériore vous
entendent rapidement un monsieur gignac
sur le fmi qui disait faut être prudent
les banques centrales en ce moment ont
tendance à brûler des munitions en
abaissant leur taux inutilement
l'aussie/yen récession par exemple qui
se pointe le bout du nez on aurait vont
être prudents oui il faut penser que
pour stimuler l'économie
je pense que la politique monétaire
reste plus beaucoup de cartouches le il
faut repenser la politique fiscale est
ce que dit le fmi aussi c'est que les
pays qui ont de la marge de manoeuvre
pour stimuler l'économie
l'onf allusion à l'allemagne en fusion
au canada on devra pas hésiter à
utiliser la politique fiscale ou
budgétaire pour venir à la rescousse
parce que les banques centrales à ussel
il reste plus beaucoup de munitions pour
soutenir l'économie si celle ci que se
détériorer
mais si gignac merci beaucoup au plaisir
à voir